[Music]  after the final Rose is gonna be on  Tuesday night we're gonna find out who  the next Bachelorette is do you think  Becca should be the next Bachelorette I  think it's pretty clear yeah why you  know we've seen Becca heartbroken now  we've seen her really happy we've seen  that she's really excited about the idea  of being committed and in a relationship  that lasts what better way to do it then  through the Bachelorette now we you know  she's at this point her heart has  already been shown to millions of people  she's been vulnerable and and with  everybody that's watching and so it just  makes sense that the rest of her story  plays out on The Bachelorette and and  hopefully she at the end of edge sees as  happy as we've seen others like Jojo and  Kaitlyn and Rachel The Bachelor has a  pretty good track record and we want  that for Becca  [Music]